there's jordan lyles
28 games for him this season this will
be his 29th see two of those were not
starts but they were extended relief
appearances coming in out of the bullpen
take a look at that 284 opponent batting
average alex breakman talk about duvet
the 2-2 pitch and a swing and a miss he
got bregman the strikeout that is out
number one oh good job by jordan miles
this is something that is pretty hard to
do 84 miles an hour with the slider
almost look like i had a curveball
action on it went straight down but
starts carlos correa
[Applause]
there's a bouncer could be two little
underhand flip to second and the relay
to first in time for the double play a
6-4-3 bottom one no score between the
astros and rangers as you see the return
of zach granky to the rotation for the
houston astros at 27 starts
11-5 366 era 110 strikeouts in 150 one
and two thirds innings last time he was
out there was august 29th against these
texas rangers right in this building he
went four innings allowed nine hits and
six earned runs he'd like to change that
as he comes back from the injured list
so it'll be up to nathaniel lowe he was
two for four yesterday two and one the
count
and that ball hit well deep out to right
field it is gone
nathaniel lowe's first ever hit against
brookie and it leaves the yard and so
the rangers get the first runs of the
night tonight it's two nothing i know we
talk a lot about nathaniel lowe and his
ability to go to the opposite field and
how he is amongst the league leaders
there but he kind of got off balance
here out front and he still hit this
ball 107 miles an hour
440 feet jose trevino down to the count
oh and two
oh yeah
zach 2801 now in the strikeout column in
his career picks up his second strike
out of the game gets trevinho on three
pitches good sliders very well located
trevino could not lay off of it back to
back center match from super bowl
starting on that outside edge and
breaking just off the plate away from
the swing nicely done here's the nine
hitter yani hernandez
ground off the middle correa snags it on
a tough hop what a play carlos correa he
is unbelievable ending the second inning
now the fans can boo out
one two pitch
and it's on the ground short stop quick
flip to second on to first in time
double play
six four three and lyles gets the twin
killing to send this game to the bottom
of the third so isaiah is on ahead of
adolesce garcia who just missed hitting
a home run in the first inning counts
two balls and a strike to adoles
this ball hit well deep out to right
center that's carrying all the way over
the fence it's gone 30th home run of the
year for adolesce garcia to the deepest
part of the park four-nothing rangers
and el boba has just tied the rangers
rookie record
with 30 home runs
this ball sounded like it was shot out
of a cannon the second that it left the
bat what a good approach from garcia to
trust in his power
and to stay up the middle the other way
and man this is a good poke center field
that deepest part of the bullpen right
there as you mentioned the deepest part
of the ballpark bregman here to start
the fourth inning
there's a bouncer left side of the
infield charging
in his throw in time to get bregman for
out number one keep in mind too with
bregman you could really tell on that
trip
down to first base he is not allowing
himself to go
100
on the sprinting down the line but
culberson had plenty of time to make
that throw here's correa and he hits
this one on the ground shortstop diving
stop ikf it's sort of first in time
i think it's correa this is a good play
at shortstop tonight two up two down
a very nice play from connor palette for
the rangers doing a little bit of
everything tonight that ball almost 100
miles an hour off the bat
look at ikf go get it get up quickly
make the throw gotta think there's some
added motivation there too when it his
counterpart i mean he even mentioned
correa last week
in a pregame zoo jose altuve get ahead
with that fastball
through and he strikes that altuve
fastball upstairs altuve went chasing
there's one away in the sixth inning you
know we talked so frequently about the
quality of a pitcher stuff
and you can really tell by the way that
hitters react and this is obviously a
very good houston lineup and they just
do not look comfortable on that box
tonight alex bregman
there's another strikeout this time
bregman goes down looking lyle's really
dialing it in here gets jose altuve on
the fastball up this is a well located
slider
dots it down and away just barely nips
that outside corner two very difficult
hitters to strike out that's impressive
now carlos correa
and a swing and a miss
he strikes out the side in order in the
sixth inning solace over two so let's
see how he recovers here the 01 pitch is
lined into right field a base hit for
nick solak garcia around third he'll
score headed to third base low
well solac makes it a five-nothing game
with his rbi single here in the sixth
kind of like we talked about in the open
see it up and hit it hard zach grinky
does not throw hard enough to where he
can throw your his fastball by you
so you wait on those breaking pitches
you try to see him up
where they're a lot easier to hit that's
a great approach from solac driving it
through so on the corners nobody out dj
peters and the count two balls and two
strikes
this ball hit well
deep out to center field and that one is
gone
peters with an absolute rope to center
field his 12th bomb of the year rangers
have opened in eight nothing leads that
grinky has been around long enough to
understand that dj peters is on his
stuff he was really going short with the
curveball trying to get him to chase and
that's what we talked about early on not
chasing to make sure that the fastball
is in your wheelhouse you said it right
18.2 degree launch angle that is a low
rocket and it knocks grenkey out of the
game
seven innings is his most innings in any
start now trying to go seven innings
tonight
might have to be a little bit careful
there's a bouncer down to first low
takes care of it it'll be interesting to
see
if lyles comes back out in the eighth
seventh shutout tonight though
and uh they'll be happy with that it's
eight nothing all right here's johnny
hernandez
johnny hernandez grounds one to short
correa to altuve and they turn the
double play on yani hernandez to end the
eighth inning we're gonna head to the
ninth
astros down ain't nothing two on nobody
out for carlos correa
correa shoots one to right field pretty
well hit garcia will watch it off the
wall nice bear hand play by adoles
altuve trying to score and he will be
safe be an rbi single for carlos correa
two they had to hustle to score that run
it's now an eight to one game as correa
drives in his 78th run of the year but
there's now one out
big 3-1 pitcher
and a bouncer could be two the second
one
on the first in time double play ball
game over sports gets it done rangers
hold on to win it eight to one the final
score and they've even this series